rising out of the north sea a mighty
feat of engineering try to know offshore
wind farms taking shape the work of an
army of newly trained apprentices
this is my going to be my first time
offshore and i'm a bit apprehensive
about that
the wind farms being erected outside on
the humber in the north sea so it's this
ideal location for me to kind of get
started
and in nearby hull this is one of the
largest manufacturers of turbine blades
in the world
each hand crafted by workers many of
whom have retrained to join the
sustainable energy sector the region
once a major coal exporter has come full
circle embracing renewable energy we
employ a thousand people on this at this
location uh in direct roles uh we had
more than 28 000 people apply for those
roles at the time it just shows how it
captures people's imagination not about
working
in blade manufacture but the whole
renewable sector
as a whole
we see potential growth as we grow and
the blade size grows as well there'll be
further jobs created not just direct
jobs but also indirect jobs to support
this industry this is engineering on a
gargantuan scale since the factory
opened only a few years ago it's
produced more than 1500 of these 80
meter long blades and very soon the
plant will be making even longer ones
meaning the factory will have to double
in size
a single turn of one of these turbines
can power a house for 24 hours
when i was a ladder just come down with
me dad all the way down this north wall
would probably be 100 steel trawlers big
ships but in the rush to decarbonize the
economy some local industries feel
sidelined darren kenyon runs the last
fishing firm in grimsby in what was the
biggest fishing port in the world
it's changed drastically i can't believe
in the last 10 years how it's how how
they managed to get rid of everybody and
you know just leave it for the win farms
anything the win farms want they get
anything we need we don't get it they're
just coming in and just doing what they
like and there's obviously people
letting them do what they like because
there's a lot of money involved in it
the transition to a greener economy
isn't just about providing more jobs
it's about making sure nobody's left
behind if we achieve net zero but we end
up with a less equal society then we've
still failed um because that will not be
sustainable and it will not address the
climate challenge um in the long term so
it does really need to engage with the
communities who are affected and get
their buy-in so they can actually lead
the action rather than being kind of
sidelined by it
eventually the oil refinery that sits at
the mouth of the humber river will have
to close as workers find new jobs
these are climate scientists hope the
last days of fossil fuels but the
climate challenge isn't just about
cutting carbon emissions it's about
securing people's futures new barker al
jazeera on the humber estuary